uh
thanks for coming uh all of you it's
very exciting to see all of you in
person with each other online a lot and
we purposefully did not open this to the
public because uh
David doesn't
I'm gonna say like the public but it's
not true uh there he is nobody felt that
uh this is really a you know a group
study meeting and should remain as such
so I I'm the direct besides being a part
of a group study uh I'm Shafi I'm the
director at Simon's Institute right here
and
um just a few words about the Simon's
Institute some of you usually we have
people that have been here many times
before but that's not the case this time
so let me tell you a little bit about us
we are a venue for collaborative
research in uh foundations of computer
science so we which we Define as
theoretical pure science plus uh
adjoining fields and we were established
in 2012 due to a very generous gift from
the Simons foundation and usually what
we do is we essentially convene people
from all over the world for programs
which are you know focused on topics
that are of Interest so we've had lots
of Topics in computational biology in
the beginning and quantum physics which
is quantum computation which keeps going
on we have a lot of data science
obviously machine learning a
cryptography security and also very
basic questions in complexity Theory and
algorithms and um we bring with postdocs
every year we have like eight postdocs
of programs so last year we had about 40
postdocs here so we are sort of a very
big convening place for postdoctoral
fellows
and uh this is a very exciting Workshop
it's a one-off so we're not part of a
semester program and as you know the
topics is the decoding Communication in
non-human species and I would like to
thank David Gruber mostly and Michael
Bronson you know mostly David for doing
so much work and I guess I should thank
myself because sometimes I answered the
emails where Chris David there thank you
David for all your efforts on behalf of
all of us and uh I guess just a few
things because David is going to say a
word about the workshop itself so
there's going to be food and all the
breaks but you only own for lunch but
you can we're not such a large group we
can sort of probably uh either do things
on your own or get into groups and we
can let you know where a good place is
to be it's kind of a break between
semesters or some things are closed so
it's good to find out from us what's
open and we ask not to bring food or
drink inside of the auditorium we're
trying to make this keep it clean their
lockers on the far side of the building
you see there if you want to leave stuff
and we have our audiographer Omid who's
going to help people in case there's a
problem this Ashley was the organizer
she's not here she's done a great job
you'll meet her throughout the day so
um without further Ado
uh I'm gonna hand over the microphone to
David
thank you all and thank you Shafi for um
for for hosting us here it's uh it's a
pleasure to kind of bring all these all
of you all together
um this is truly uh interdisciplinary
type meeting and just some background is
you know on what the project or or how
this is all fits together is that uh
project steady the the citation
translation initiative
um kind of the ideas began
um in 2017 2018 when we were all
radcliffellos that uh at Harvard and
started to see the power of uh of
putting um putting different groups of
people together to uh to better
understand nature
um and then this project has really
grown Through The Years included many
people in this room now and hoping
threat through the through this meeting
it'll include even more people
um you know and really our motive here
is to uh
um listen to and translate the the
communication system of sperm whales and
we're building on Shane garrow's work in
the in the Caribbean and Dominica where
where have 15 years of Legacy data that
has been really instrumental in this
project so
um uh just as background you know we're
covering many different disciplines here
we have um people even in law Cesar that
are thinking about non-human rights
Linguistics natural language processing
artificial intelligence dolphin biology
cryptography
um people looking at this from music
roboticist Rob wood are our our lead of
um of Robotics for the project and we
also want to acknowledge the the support
of ocean kind
um and Bryce for really providing us the
support for putting this this meeting
together just to kind of start off
though one one note is uh over the
weekend we we lost one of our our
members of our team
um Roger Payne who in 1960s discovered
that uh that whale sing and um
it was a real kind of um it was
considered a senior advisor for our team
and but he's really a close friend and
uh and a mentor to all of us and um you
know through the time since the very
beginning of the project he'd been with
us since the since day one in a
conference we'd held in 2019 at
Radcliffe that that really kind of went
from this going from an idea to this is
possible and um Roger just wrote a piece
in Time Magazine about six days ago
um where he really he reiterates that um
the work that he had done that began to
save the whale Campaign which was one of
the most successful environmental
movements in history he really had hopes
and dreams that this project and this
kind of collaboration this kind of
interdisciplinarity could um could be
the next step and and lead to all sorts
of goodness that that um that uh
we we hope to actualize so um yeah thank
you everyone for being here
um there's a kind of really sweet of uh
diverse talks and um we kind of
organized this rather small so there
could be lots of synergy probably the
the the best part of this will be in the
side conversations as always
um and thank you Shafi for hosting this
dinner at your house tonight
um so so yeah just what
yeah everyone has that so so yeah we're
just really hoping to to expand our
community and and build community and
friendships and collaborations and and
really showing the power of um of
bringing people together is uh um and
what we can do together is uh is a lot
more than we could do on on our own so
um I'll start with that and uh first up
well there's gonna be one shift those
um friends um friends Jensen was
supposed to be here but um it has some
um some issues so he's not able to come
but he'll be the presenting remotely so
it'll be the one remote presentation
um and that'll actually he can't do it
later so we'll we'll do that after this
talk so I'll try to figure out how so
Brian will come in the afternoon he's
good with that so so thank you for that
and I'll figure out how we set up the
zoom for that coming up and um so yeah
start out with the first talk uh Antonio
let me know
can you hear me
from the speakers yeah thanks
[Music]
foreign
just a second we need to plug in
sorry
all right
um well first of all I would like to
thank the director of The Institute and
all the organizers for having us here
today
um
so I'm very excited about this project
and I'm going to present some recent
work and some ongoing work that I've
been doing with my students
University of Rome
um I would like to start with a funny
story so Antonio is now um visiting A
technion is anyone from the technion
here
Michael
okay so Antonio usually has lunch on a
Terrace at the computer science
department and he used to to tell me
that this
guys from the technion are very unpolite
and very unkind because there is a trash
can and all the trash is outside of the
of the trash can okay so I mean if the
trash can is there why don't you put
your trash inside
inside the can instead of
outside of the can
and after a few weeks
we found the culprit so the culprit is
this guy down here
so this this raven learned
to pull out the trash from the from the
bean by
biting the plastic bag bag and turning
it inside out so that all the trash
falls out and then after it's done
can look for food
okay so apologies for for
accusing your students to do this
um all right so you will agree with with
me that well you we can think of this as
some kind of intelligent Behavior by by
this raven
and in particular
this raven is applying well is
performing some pretty predictive or
some prediction act right so it knows
that if it pulls out the stuff from the
trash bin it will likely find some food
some spare food on the ground okay so
and this is very very impressive very
surprisingly and also very funny
but this is of course uncomparable to
what we can do as humans
as predictors so what I'm showing here
is a solar eclipse so we as humans we
are able to predict precisely the year
the month the week the day and the
precise time when the next solar eclipse
will happen
and we are able also to provide an
explanation as to when this will happen
we also can explain why we know the
underlying mechanism that is rise to
this kind of phenomenon
and these we can do with the with the
with very high precision and with a
a lot a lot of time a very long time in
advance
and this is again this is a predictive
act and if we compare this with what the
Raven can do you can see that the main
difference even just by looking at the
slide I mean different lies in us being
able to provide an explanation behind
the phenomena okay
all right so we have this mapping
between what we learned about nature and
what we can explain
have you seen this movie this is don't
look up
so if you didn't watch the movie well
it's a it's a very funny story it's like
kind of a dark comedy and we as
scientists will really
appreciate the pain if you watch the
movie you you will you will really enjoy
it so at the beginning of the movie this
is not a spoiler this is just the
beginning of the movie
um DiCaprio
he's a scientist some some
astrophysicist of some kind and he's
sitting in his office and then he's
doing some calculations and then he
suddenly realizes that a comet is going
to crash on the planet and this is gonna
be an apocalyptic event okay so he is
very scared of this and of course the
scientists here never experienced such a
catastrophic phenomena but still he is
able to predict precisely when it's
gonna happen and what the consequences
will be
so if we compare this with what the the
Raven did in the previous video well we
can one way to put it is that the Raven
has a very slow learning process
throughout throughout its life and then
when it learns about a new phenomenon
and then the Raven dies well
the new generations will have to relearn
from scratch
we as humans we are able to communicate
what's what we learned about some
natural phenomenon to the Next
Generation okay so this is this is a
crucial difference between between the
two and I want to give an explicit
example as to why communicating well as
to why creating explanations and then
communicating these explanations and
then using the explanations to
do predictions is so crucial also for us
humans
so we are from we are from Rome and I
don't know if you if you ever been here
this is the pantheon in Rome
and the Dome of the pantheon uses some
special kind of concrete and this kind
of concrete this was invented by the by
the Romans several centuries ago now the
the interesting thing about this this
kind of concrete is that the formula for
this concrete was lost
so it was lost centuries ago
and then there was no explanations no
nobody ever wrote or we never discovered
an explanation for the formula so it was
rediscovered it had to be rediscovered
several centuries afterwards because we
missed the communication step
and well this this formula was very
important because this Roman concrete
has some particular regenerative
properties some elasticity properties
that that make it very very important
well funny thing uh
recently like 10 years ago there was
some some progress on on this formula
and this is actually coming from UC UC
Berkeley okay
um so to improve today's concrete do as
the Romans did this was this was the the
news uh the news on the on the UC
Berkeley website
so communicating explanations is an
important thing and it this is probably
what makes us unique as a species
foreign okay
all right so how do we create progress
in in science what makes what we call
Knowledge today is this collection
collection of
of explanations that we communicate
throughout the generations okay so this
collection is what we call Knowledge
today
all right so what we're going to show in
this in this talk so I'm going to leave
the stage to Antonio to do that
I'm going to show how we can endow a
machine with these capabilities these
capabilities of understanding exist
existing explanations from for some
phenomenon and also to create new
explanations for new phenomena
for an unseen phenomena
and these is basically what a human
scientist would do so in this sense we
call this process of understanding and
creating explanations and artificial
scientist process
we're gonna do this
by
appealing to the notion of language so
and this is going to be even more
interesting than this because we're
going to do this without actually
teaching the language to the machine
so everything will be
will go in a sense end to end so
learning the language and then using it
to understand explanations and then
creating new explanations for new
phenomena
so this is what we call a machine
scientist
with this and done so I'm going to leave
the stage for Anton
okay so in this introvert from Emma we
learned that
if you want to imitate humans in this
process of making powerful predictions
of the future with Attitude trying to
mimic this
uh particular system based on
explanations which
led us to
potentially artificial scientists and
which will be very similar to mastering
a language
okay
so how can we build such an artificial
scientists
okay so the
the basic process is to come out with
new theories from data
uh we call this this problem in
philosophy epistemology so the creation
of new knowledge
and historically this this problem has
seen two different sides uh empiricism
reaction lists
um
the first belief that
okay knowledge comes primarily from the
sensory experience so from outside
and
while the rationalists believe that the
main process is from our faculty of
reasons so
what really matters is uh
from our insights so from our prayers
um
today we will try to actualize this
position in the context of AI and deep
learning so
when we have a machine that learns
something from data
how we should do it how we are doing it
like in the impurities way or on the
rationalist way and can we learn
something from
from the past
okay first thing we know that standard
end-to-end deep learning is aligned with
the in previous View so we have this
big model we have a lot of data and
we assume that we can read the theory in
data so
we do not really come out with some
hypotenuse a priority
yeah we can put some prior in the
architecture but
ultimately for example last year's that
is this Universal architecture
Transformer which is kind of
uh catching or problems and we just
learned it end to end end to end if the
theory is very complex no worries we'll
just use a bigger Network
if it is super complex we just use a
huge Network
and this is there's called bitter lesson
from Rich Saturn uh okay you can come
out with some fancy ideas for the
architectures um
really nuances on the data that we can
exploit to maybe use a little less
compute but in the end what really works
is just having more data as a bigger
Network
and actually we
had very big achievements following this
rule
here I show just two this is Alpha star
uh
uh system from deepmind capable of
building at least Sometimes the best
player in Starcraft 2 what is believed
to be the hardest video game
in ever created the place
uh at least professionally
and or GPT for something that now we are
very used to
incredible capabilities uh better
substantially just on the
the simple task of predicting the next
token but with a lot of data a lot of
computes and I use neural network
okay uh
we have to say this
lesson provides very impressive results
but have some downsides
training this uh
networks is very expensive like millions
of dollars
indeed
for example for Alpha star uh
here the data set had to be generated
so there is a simulator of the of the
process it is a video game
and this system learned equivalently
unlike of 200 years 24 hours per day
of playing
so to generate all this data and then to
learn on all this data is a very
expensive project uh a very expensive
problem
and
yeah the other downside is that
for not every problem actually for very
little we have a simulator that we can
generate infinite data
um
some some processes is very costly to to
get the data
and for some problems we may also be
close to the
to the limit of the available data and
with the gpt4 this is already becoming a
concern
okay so uh is there an alternative route
to The Bitter lesson to just collect a
lot of data and
some evidence suggests that this is
what I'm talking about
this is one of the last world champion
of soccer and actually was capable of
beating the the system of a star and for
sure he had not learned Starcraft
playing 200 years 24 hours per day
how he is able to do this
or
scientists
scientists do not need millions of
examples to come up with a new Theory
and still
their uh
their explanations are really truly our
progress so
can we try to mimic more
how a scientist operates and works to
for our future machine learning
algorithms
okay so this is the basic intuition of
our work uh
that's all now we should start from here
so how does a scientist work
but I hear we
we listen from
a scientists what what he says about the
the scientific method this is a lesson
from 1964 situation now I'm going to
discuss how he would look for a new law
in general we look for a new law by the
following process first we get it
then we don't laugh that's really true
that
okay
Okay so
basic principle from Feynman okay how
scientists discover new law first thing
they guessed them okay what does it mean
this really seems uh what we were
talking before seems that we kind of
made a restaurant it's perspective ship
so
we need to put Theory before data
okay not exactly Theory conjectures
specifically classifiable conjectures
I will give you an example
this is a recent successful prediction
from scientists here I'm showing you the
data used for this prediction this new
piece of knowledge
actually I'm not showing you a sample
from the data set this is the data set
all the data set needed to do this
prediction is here
so these two samples what I'm talking
about
someone else recognizing what you're
talking about
exactly
so here are these two signals recorded
on the East and the west coast of the
United States
and this is the Eco of the gravitational
waves generated by the Collision of two
black holes one of 29 solar masses and
one of 36 solar masses
they collided together like billions
years
away from the earth and we recorded the
equal in gravitational waves of this
event
now think about it
all this knowledge about what has
happened here so these two black holes
at this distance of this solar mass
research
causing
waves of this kind
how can you read all this information
just in the data it's clear that the
theory should have came first
and in this case came exactly one
century in advance the specialty theory
of relativity by Albert Einstein
okay
so asaya researchers what we can learn
from this how can we build system closer
to the working of scientists
and now we arrive to
the substance of our work which is
explanatory learning
okay
so
first we need to formalize the
scientific
problem
uh
to make it digestible by machine
here is a quote from Georgia parisia
recent number laboratory physics from
Sapienza our University
what is the what is scientific discovery
what is the scientific process and he
made this analogy with puzzles so so
many people spend their time doing
puzzles
that's it researchers like putting
together pieces that not seem to be
linked with each other except that if
one solves them they become Heritage of
menka so John Japanese is making this
analogy between
discovering the explanation of a
phenomenon and solving a puzzle
and we can really see this at the big
for example at the beginning of the
scientific era here is Galileo
um
and this is a
his notes about the satellites of
Jupiter
so he part and this is his telescope
towards Jupiter and discovered this four
little points around Jupiter and
annotated their position over the days
um
here I kind of simplified the notes so
some observations are
we went to what he could see at the time
some are not like he never seen two
points aligned in a vertical
in a vertical sense
and he made this observations and then
came out with an explanation
uh
in this case this is a name it's right
from this is
for wandering Stars having the appeared
around a physical style so
what he has seen is coherent with this
explanation why other observations are
not good
it's an interesting parallel
the first you have to guess the solution
which is not the case here
I
actually here I'm
yeah I'm showing that he
uh reservations and then there's a
theory yeah but
this this is the final outcome but now
we will look closer how the process of
coming out in this theory has really
happened and now we are trying to
formalize a problem and we build this on
top of the
try to remove phenomenon so we build
this
artificial phenomenon
it's a little Universe of dramatic
figures called Odin
um
here the problem is analogous so we have
some structures
we know in advance that these structures
are coherent with some
rule of nature of this simple Universe
of geometric shapes in this case for
example
there should be exactly one blue
surrounded by triangles for example this
structure is coherent we distribute
nature there is one blue surrounded by
triangles
this is not coherent because this blue
is surrounded by triangles but also this
blue so they are true and it's not
exactly one
so
here we are making this parallel
this is a phenomenon of nature there is
a
law of nature governing it and
the job of a scientist is to find this
law of nature
okay
now how can we do this
uh
okay this is the explanatory learning
problem
so we assume to observe a new phenomenon
so we do not know the law of nature in
advance we just have some observations
like Olivia
is this enough no this is not enough
this is a very limited set of
observations we can craft any
explanation that can be coherent with
this little data and here we come to the
to the point
so we have to assume something else what
we assume we assume to have already
some explanations for some already
explaining phenomena so
this is uh mimicking like
the work of the scientists of the past
so
uh
science is in this sense
using a language which is understandable
to
to others to communicate an explanation
which will makes us able to make new
predictions of the phenomenon of
interest and how can we learn this
language we need some data on this
and this is given by the past
explanations
but we should look at this
at these past explanations as if they
were in a known language
so we are trying to model in the problem
of becoming a scientist but from being
like a child so a baby is not able to uh
look at a science book learn the
uh
like formulas for astrophysics and make
prediction about eclipses he first have
to learn the language
which these formulas are communicated
then under so that he can understand
them or she and then using this formulas
will be able to make these predictions
and eventually
there will be a new phenomenon
that no one has already discovered an
explanation for them
she or he will discover this explanation
and write it in the same language so
that then the next generation will be
able to
use them to make predictions
okay
last thing we need to formalize the
problem
actually
there may be different way to
phrase
an explanation for this phenomenon
like there are different way to write
for example the law of general
relativity and many of them are
are coherent so we do not want to
uh evaluates
the process just by looking at every
symbol
should be exactly as we expect we want
that the meaning
of the
output explanation is
coherent with with what we want so
instead of
looking at the outwards explanation we
have some
test samples to make prediction on in
this case like 1 000 new structures we
have to predict
their coherence or not with the rule of
nature
and
and then that's it in in our
formalization if
our system will be able to make the
correct prediction for
the new structures we will say that he
had Discord the explanation
okay so this is the final problem
we are given
some observation so
some structures
with the the tag if they are coherent or
not with
the law of network the phenomenon then
we are given
a new structure and we will be asked to
if this structure is coherental or not
with the rule of nature of that
phenomenon
and our problem is to find this F
that has this binary input output
okay
so how can we find this F we can just
train a neural network and to end this
would be the empiricist approach
um
we would see that this approach
this approach is based on a parametric
hypothesis which is represented by the
weights in this case of the neural
network
and we should be continuously updated
during the training so during the
training will be the gradients that are
adjust the weights and since our
hypothesis is the weights of neural
network visible this is continuously
updated through the training process
and
we will see that this will go some
transition gaps so literally in the
performance of
how much we'll be able to solve this
problem
then
every prediction made about this system
is not really explainable
um
we will see in in which sense this kind
of relation is unreal reliable
and and also there is this strange thing
that
very simple phenomenon or very complex
phenomena really are requiring the same
amount of computation and this is kind
of opposite to our intuition about the
problem
okay uh how can we instead think a
rationalist approach towards this
problem
so in the rationalized approach we need
uh we have said that we want the theory
coming first so
the conjecture coming first so we need
to model some sort of creative act that
generates this conjecture a better
several conjectures
and then we have to model the process of
falsification so where we take these
conjectures one by one
We compare them
with the data we have
the data may be coherent with the
conjectures
or not coherent with a conjecture in
this case we will discard the conjecture
okay so we try to model this process how
we model it
this is exactly
the
process described by popper
about
how science work in in his work called
critical rations and
so we
model this process through two neural
networks
a conjecture generator and an
interpreter
or notice that here
the hypothesis is no more the weights of
the network here the hypotheses are this
language prepositions created by this
conjecture generator that then can only
be accepted or refused or refused in
their entirety
okay
so uh
how we implement this this idea
on the empiricious side this is just an
intramural Network
on the rationally side we have this two
neural networks
uh
here the construction generator
regenerates some conjectures in
a language which will will be
interpreted by The Interpreter
which takes an input
a conjecture a rule
and a structure and
how this
do models are trained we're supposed to
have this data set of
we're already upset
this phenomenon already explained so
explanations in a known language so we
do not making we do not make any
assumption on the map on the language
this is just
a sequence of symbols
and for each phenomenon really explain
we have the sequence of symbols and then
some Target structures so structures and
the tag that says to us if this
structure is coherent with the rule
these are known sequence of symbol or
not coherent
we train the conjecture generator to
generate
the sequence of symbol
from the observations so we train it in
the empiricist direction so to generate
the
explanation from the data
but we do not stop there we train also
an interpreter
in the opposite direction so we trained
interpreter to take in input
the explanation that we have then we
take
one of the observation we have we remove
the tag we give the structure an input
interpreter and we want The Interpreter
to predict the attack
so we train the two system in this way
while for the end-to-end model we just
predict train the model to
take an input
a collection of
structures of Target structures a new
structure and to predict the tag of the
instructor
okay all these neural networks are
Transformer actually use the very same
architecture and
a model for
the conjecture generator The Interpreter
and the
and then to end pieces model adjusting
some
some pieces to have the correct inputted
outputs but in the end the two models
have are almost the same number of
learnable parameters so that they are
comparable
um
we actually trained two kinds of
empiricist models one that just predicts
the attack
and then also one that tried to predict
in output also the
symbolic explanation so you should
assume to have here in the conscious
empiricist model another arrow that
tries to guess the symbolic explanation
okay
so now we are two experiments so first
thing we compare
these two approaches so the critical
restaurant networks and the previous
models train them to end
Okay so
uh
a note about the data set so we
generated this data set
of
phenomenon in this Odin universe
we are like 1400 phenomenon in training
each phenomenon has 1000 of
Target observations
and then a test we have 1000 new
phenomena so with explanation completely
different from the one from training but
it used the same language
um so how it does this uh these two
models we test them on finding the
explanation for the 1000 completely new
phenomenon
um sorry it's the explanation unique not
necessarily right it's pretty sure it's
not necessarily unique uh in in two
senses so
in the language we have built for this
universe uh the very same expression may
be uh
uh phrased in different ways for example
you can say there should be at least
one pyramid and Atmos one pyramid this
is equivalent to saying there should be
exactly one pyramid so you need some
kind of parsimony right some kind of
outcome tracer
yeah so
in our work we just
uh
want to see that the explanation is
correct so even if you provide the
longest one
for us it's okay but clearly one can
Implement some
kind of Pokemon razor in in this step
and
is like a positive way to the shorter
explanations
okay so these are the the the results so
on 1000 new phenomenon the critical
restaurants network is able to discover
the explanation the correct explanation
for
more than 700 of them while the best and
previous model stops at 200 please to
that question so if there's nothing
incentivizing the conjecture generator
to
to you know
worse than fixed time thinking right
because then it might scale with the
number of samples
uh
practical data yeah memorizing the the
samples will not work because it won't
generalize but yeah it might still scale
somehow with the number of samples like
the number of
conjectures needed to generate like to
do a forward pass through your whole
train thing okay it might grow the
number of samples which is worse than if
you have a fixed architecture yeah
except there is this very relevant
parameter here which is how many
conjectures we are generating and
actually this is a nice thing because we
can come to this permission like if we
expect that the the low is very simple
or maybe we have a lot of data here then
we can just generate maybe two three
five conjectures because we expect the
projector generator to already do a good
job but
if we expand the problem to be difficult
then maybe we can let the conjecture
generator generate many conjectures then
then we all test so this is some like
you're like biasing the the network
because you have some prior knowledge
over the problem
yeah or yeah maybe prior knowledge of
just how much resources to AF to spend
on this
yeah if it's the former then
it would be fit like the problem with
the with the fixed uh I can't see it now
but in the fourth Arrow here the fixed
thinking time was that you're using one
architecture for simple apps and for
complex apps
yeah where if I knew how complex my f
was in advance I would like to use
less parameters for simple apps and more
parameters for more complex apps okay
so the Apples to Apples comparison would
be adding this bias to
that big slime
no and
I'm just saying um I'm just thinking uh
and I'll stop now because I don't wanna
oh okay back up but um
shouldn't then
like if you're if you are uh letting the
your model scale with the complexity of
the No No but the model is not scary
actually the the number of random
parameters is almost the same and in the
end the increases model has more
parameters because that's two different
backgrounds but it's it's almost the
same actually using the very same
architecture
the point is that there we can exploit
search yeah well here
yeah you can do some sort of search
because it's a Transformer so
you can do like a beam search on the
explanation predicted but this search is
not as effective as a search like in the
conjecture space
I see
so yeah I I don't mean the number of
parameters I mean the total
for a forward pass through the model
OKAY clearly clearly if you want to
check many conjectures you need more
time but the point is
okay suppose I give you more time here
what you can do
yeah
so you you just do not have a way to
spend this more time so is this just to
make sure I understand is the empiricist
model like is this a meta liner it's
conditioning on the entire input data
set and then making predictions in the
output data set or is it just like a
classifier that you're optimizing on a
little data set
is just a classifier so it's a binary
classifier okay and in input there is
some observations from the new
phenomenon okay 32 actually so you so on
this set of a thousand phenomena you're
learning one
set of parameters and then yeah exactly
except and so this input
is exactly this so yeah
we're supposed to have okay there is a
new Phenomenon with a new explanation
we're supposed to have 32 observations
of this phenomenon so structure Target
and we want the model to discover the
correct explanation not really this
common definition but to be able to tag
correctly 1000 more structures of this
phenomenon
and
here the the metric we are interested to
is this NRS
and yeah just the the rationalized way
is
much better than in previous one this is
an example from the test set so these
are the observations
this is the ground root rule so there
should be at most one blue pyramid
pointing Gap
this year end came out with
this rule zero blue or at most one blue
building pointing up which actually is
equivalent to this one there is this
zero blue which is or which is not
really necessary with some sort of
outcome razor we call that
discard it while the this is the rule
for from the increases conscious model
so the one that also try to predict the
the rule zero one blue touching or or
actually we do not have any
guarantee also that the
the output rule here but also for the
bridges model is really a
correct grammarly speeding
okay so okay
I just wanted to ask so to specify the
generalization is in learning the
language right so you are not trying to
learn from previous rules to the new
rules right so the generation only in
the internal representation
I mean how much uh
the model is able to
find the correct explanation for new
phenomena and make predictions for new
phenomenon so this is another phenomena
unrelated to the new ones unlike let's
say real science or probably you can
draw an analogies between things that
you that you learn right laws of nature
repeat themselves maybe in different
contexts at different scale so here you
see but it's completely updated yeah
yeah
the the assumption that we think hold
source of real science is that during
real science if we discover something
new for a new phenomenon we will break a
paper which will be in the same language
of the older graders this is the crucial
idea so if we discover a new thing for
an economy maybe we introduce a new
meaning for a word this happens a lot of
time but the paper is in English and if
officials read the
it's a favorite about the special
relative information
he's able to understand it because he
knows the language so here we here we've
modeled
also the process of mastering this
language to be able to understand this
extraction
so from like the the Practical point of
view the difference in in the model is
it actually the especially training time
the only difference is this kind of
bottleneck layer on the crn where you
are forced to Output like a sequence of
characters yeah
I will not put emphasis on the fact that
this is about that I mean
in some sense yes this is important
because
this space is more so we can search in
this space but I think also there is
another important
thing to move home from here is that
here there are two directions
in in this problem one is from the data
to the explanation and the other one is
from the explanation to the data and
which may resemble so the codes
available
in the council
learning the literature
and one of the two is much simpler to
learn which is the one from the
explanation to the data so the job of
The Interpreter
also we have this intuition that is
Sinker we have to learn given an
explanation
given a structure
say if this structure is coherent or not
with this explanation and this is a much
simpler problem that okay I give you
this 32
structures give me the correct
explanation
and here the idea is since this
direction is much easier to learn can we
exploit a model very good at doing this
to
relief
and
make it make work also a model in the
direction we are interested in
but which is not that good and this is
exactly what is happening here
okay another cool thing of this model is
that
this uh the final prediction the
prediction of
uh attack for a new structure is very
interpretable like
this is uh
a bit forward thinking but imagine to
have
a machine learning algorithm like this
for a bank which is deciding if giving
you a loan or not uh
so okay London so the the output is for
our extractor so for example my profile
for the bank is okay no you will not get
a loan
but this prediction will come from an
explanation in a language
that can be for example okay to not pay
the loan in the past and you are
resident in a district with a high rate
of insolvenance
now we are able to understand this
explanation
and we can say okay but this is
unacceptable to me because why the
the loan should be based on
the on where you live and we can just
discard this explanation put another one
here
to not pay the loan in the past and then
we get
we are guaranteed to get a new
prediction which is based not which is
based on the new
on the new explanation that we had
there so
we have some control on
on the input then interpretation is
given by the model
so this is exactly what I do for my job
interviews hosted trees because we need
to provide Sharpie values
and so my question would be would you be
able to hook up a CRM to an existing
model which would be deep learning based
design
whether this person is a good borrower
or not but you'll be able to distill
that with a CNN and output explanation
like this
okay
this is our vision so we have tested it
on this toy problem or in this universe
of dramatic figures but here there is
this so you could you replace the
universe of geometrically your sweet
amount
of the Improvement
uh to me the answer is yes and the point
is to frame the problem as an
interpretation problem so
if you can link your prediction to an
explanation which is in a language then
you can use the this CRM framework to
learn an interpreter rather than for
example
a common approach especially at the
beginning of the interpretation
research was to apply produce an
explanation passed up so you you have a
prediction that you're a model that
given the prediction gives a reasonable
explanation
and this is uh to meet this this is
unacceptable from interpretation point
of view
well here
the prediction is caused by the
explanation if if we altered explanation
we are guaranteed to have a prediction
with which is based upon the output
explanation so just for your example
right so you could train and boost the
tree on and out of a deep learning model
but that will not pass like legally in
America they cannot decline somebody
because you have a surrogate model okay
that's right so that's the parts of the
problem as you said it's not it's not
acceptable yeah
okay
please
I'm just wondering
you're probably building to something
and I'm wondering and since this is a
workshop on communicating with other
species I'm wondering what you're
building to with this in hypothesizing
something about
communicating with other states yeah so
uh
here uh we have made this strong
connection with
the problem of the scientists so coming
out with an explanation which is based
so what the scientist is doing is
solving a communication problem kind of
the for the next Generations
and
if we want to solve the problem of the
scientists we cannot assume to have
to know the language in advance so we
have to assume to have this explanation
written in a known language
us
the language for example of another
species
and so the the strong parallel and this
is the last thing the last experiment I
will show is that
here the data from which we are learning
are observation from the nature which
here are this
instructors in this geometric figure
process and
some symbolic sequences
that are in a known language and to
which we do not need any assumption so
we will not be addressing that this is
English or for end yet so
this is a Showcase of what we can do
with uh
the desert of this kind so
some
sequence of symbols which we assume they
are describing something in nature
and some observation from the
phenomena's major we're interested
and
actually
we started working on this from the
scientist perspective so okay how can we
imitate scientists then we realize this
strong connection with language
and this is why we are here
but then there is the final experiment
we think is very
I think it's the one that interests us
the most in this respect
okay
uh
uh okay this is another good thing of
the construction that
when we check all the conjectures with
data if no conjectures is compatible
with the data we have we just discard
all of them and we output on a known
token which is a thing that in the
end-to-end setting is just
not possible
um yeah that is what we were discussing
before so that we have control on the on
on this variable how many conjectures we
should generate
and if we expect if we have more compute
or we expect for some reason for some
biasa
more complex phenomenon uh we can just
let the conjecture generator try more
and then we will test all the conjecture
with interpreters
okay
okay now we come to the experiment that
yeah
uh this is the the final thing I have to
say
uh then we made this final experiment so
here we are comparing two different crn
models
so now we focus on The Interpreter in
one case we use the Learned interpreter
so the Transformer trained on the on the
data set
and then we compare this crn model with
the learner interpreter with a crn model
that use The Interpreter
brought by us to generate the data set
because uh we have generated the
yeah
synthesizes the this dramatic figure
data set so we wrote an interpreter in
Python
um
so this interpreter can
replace The Interpreter of the crn model
and we can use it to
discover the new explanation this
interpreter clearly is perfect he will
never
give a wrong prediction for a structure
differently from
the Learned interpreter which is very
good
uh 99.9 accuracy on giving the correct
tag for a structure but it's not perfect
now uh
the experiment we made is okay
which crn is better in finding the
explanation for the
new phenomena
the crn using the Learned interpreter or
the Syrian using the recording
interpreter
and now the surprising fact is that
when the London interpreter is
very good so close to 100 but not
necessarily
predicting the the correct tax 100 of
the time
this year using the Learned interpreter
performs better than the one with their
code interpreter the ground with one
and why is this the case I mean the our
code interpreter is perfect never
happens that you have for example there
should be at least one red and here is
predicted run if
will always give the
the good prediction
so the point is that
generating the the conjectures is a
difficult task we do not make any
assumption on the language here so
sometimes the
the conjectures generated are not
respecting the grammar of the language
and when this happens
there could interpreter just Brooks
and even if here there is a simple
a simple swap or or maybe
announced that is not altering the
meaning but it's just altering the
the grammar like when we have like a
missing comma Industry Program
so Michael was mentioning dialects in
the whale language so if you have
different dialects and those sequences
or symbols are available
to the the presence of a ballot
yeah for example here I think that here
are a bigger takeaway is that to learn a
language one should be able to be
resistant to this
uh
slide alteration of the grammar and
and still figure out I mean uh
like here
we show how
to do this really interpreter should be
learned and cannot be encoded
okay
so
let's see
um
to summarize again yeah this summarize
the the four parts we discussed before
but uh
in the conclusion I made the the three
main takeaways I think
are are relevant for for this Workshop
respect to our work so
the problem of mastering a language is
very similar to the problem of
creating an artificial scientist in the
sense of
finding the explanation for a new
phenomenon
putting a language hypothesis space in
the middle of a deep learning model
is
uh
can be a good thing for a number of
reasons like interpretability like
more transition with the same amount of
data and the same amount of compute at
Visa training
and that
if you are interested in
in learning uh
a language to make predictions so not
to learn to make just a
perfect string of symbols we desire then
we need
A system that is couple of interpreting
simple autonomy autonomously so we
cannot our codes being types of the
meaning of the symbols
um
that's it thank you
[Applause]
uh so quick question um well maybe with
the positions in the context of
non-human uh species communication so we
often have some communication of let's
say from Wales plus some behavioral
information or they may be chatting and
then for example decide to dive uh so in
your context that would be the basically
the alternative to this binary labels
right so we can for example uh ask the
question whether certain communication
uh is really truly a certainly
behavioral pattern now I think the main
difference here that I see is that we
have a lot of clutter right so you have
maybe some pattern that is indicative of
that communication that let's dive but
you also have some other stuff that you
don't know that might be completely
irrelevant maybe part of a different
conversation so how would that be
modeled uh in your approach okay uh here
what what I was imagining is that for
example
uh we'll say that in which communication
yeah we have these clicks which are the
main language for us and so our best
string of symbols here
and here this modeling I think is very
powerful because we do not have to make
any assumptions
and I'm pairing with this we have some
information from the context like
uh the body language maybe some the
wheels are making maybe what we are
reducing with the drones
and this might be here like okay this
body language we have registered it but
never with the whale saying this so this
body language is not happening with this
particular saying
uh or maybe we here we can have okay
this thing is always said when there are
there is a wheel slipping for example so
this is way utility
so
this is uh
how I imagine to to use the sequence of
the genetic symbols in your example is
actually the observable phenomena right
so that would probably correspond to the
to the clicks whereas the language will
be something latent some some kind of
your internal representation into which
you're translated so to say
okay this is another
itself
and then this having like maybe
the English translation
yeah
questions
we'll stop here and we'll continue more
questions later
okay
thank you thank you
[Applause]